good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am very proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2021 2022 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence and biomedicine
where we enjoy presentations on fridays from
leading thinkers about the promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with ai applications in
the biomedical sciences selected participants
in our biomedical data sciences innovation
lab program will leverage these presentations
as vital material for our upcoming culminating
in-person grant project development workshop to
be held here in historic charlottesville virginia
in june today i am very delighted to welcome
my new friend and our speaker today colin
allen from the university of pittsburgh colin
earned his phd from ucla in 1989 and since 2017 he
is the distinguished professor in the department
of history and philosophy of science at the
university of pittsburgh allen's main areas
of research concern the philosophical foundations
of cognitive science particularly as these relate
to scientific study of animal cognition and
artificial intelligence his publications
also span topics in the philosophy of mind
philosophy of biology and humanities computing
with over 120 research articles and several
edited and co-authored books including moral
machines teaching robots right from wrong oxford
unity university press 2009 and species of mind
from mit press in 1997. he receives some of
his funding from the templeton world charity
foundation's diverse intelligence intelligences
initiative in continuing the 2021-2022
excuse me biomedical data science uh seminar
series theme collins lecture today will be
entitled on collective wisdom when ai is involved
colin asks an important question why despite often
good intentions are ai deployments so prone to
unanticipated failures in his talk he is going
to diagnose some recent failures of ai including
the use of machine learning uh as due to a failure
of collective wisdom and emerging from the work
done with his colleague brett carlin colin will
describe an engineered concept of wisdom that
can be extended to groups of people providing a
framework for collective wisdom at various stages
of an ai project from conception to development
to marketing and deployment to end users as
always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube if you are watching on
youtube thank you so much for joining us also our
specially selected uh 2021-2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants
are strongly encouraged to submit any questions
for call and via the chat feature in the zoom
sessions i will take it upon myself to synthesize
these questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that colin welcome we are really looking
forward to your lecture today thank you so much
jack thanks so much for that introduction and i'm
really happy to be here um yes i'm going to try
and tell you about a couple of what i see of those
failures of collective wisdom in a couple of ai
applications they're not biomedical applications
but i think that the lessons easily generalize
and in fact in this project that i'm doing
with brett as funded by the twcf as you mentioned
we are trying to develop a framework for thinking
through how um at all the various different stages
of development of an ai application um the the uh
the kinds of considerations that that
are important get properly addressed
at each of those stages so the two failures of
collective wisdom that i'm going to talk about
are represented here on the left many of you will
know the case of the fatality where a self-driving
so-called self-driving autonomous vehicle owned
by uber ran over and killed this woman who's
pushing her bicycle across the street which you
see in the right frame on the left hand side here
and left frame is the dash cam both these dash cam
pointing different directions of the woman who was
in the vehicle and supposedly overseeing
the operation of this autonomous vehicle
and i'll have more to say about that in a moment
the right one um many of you may have uh heard
about this in in the fall but it made some amount
of national press but i'm not sure if if everyone
will have heard about it and that was the release
of some software by the allen institute for ai
which is based in seattle washington um it's no
relation to me um paul allen was co-founder of
microsoft with bill gates so it's funded by a
foundation that he established and asked delphi
was proposed as a kind of moral machine oracle
so again i will talk about this in more detail
but show ways in which that particular project
went wrong in which the developers of that
project acknowledged some of their mistakes but
in my view not all of them and it contained some
important lessons for us i think but here's
an example of a way in which delphi went wrong
so this is delphi version one the original release
being in october of last year where you could type
in a scenario for it such as this one should i
commit genocide if it makes everybody happy until
we would respond you should um and that's clearly
a bad response and the question is how given the
uh you know dozens if not hundreds of people
working on this project uh did this kind of
response get through uh whatever checks that they
supposedly put on it before they released it to
the public and i'll talk about how they've handled
that since and whether or not it's adequate
um so the general framing here then is that real
world applications of ai or machine learning
machine learning and i'm treating those um roughly
equivalently at the moment we could discuss that
if necessary but these are increasingly
ubiquitous as i'm sure you're all aware
much of the ai ethics focuses on technical issues
such as the explainability of the algorithms or
bias in the data sets but i'm going to try
to argue in conjunction with this project
that we have that more attention to wisdom in
the design construction marketing and use of ai
has practical significance um and i'll try to
spell that out as we go through and i'm also
going to put this in the context of work that
i have been doing for the last 20 plus years
my first article in this space was
this rather pretentiously titled
prolagomena to any future artificial moral agent
that was back when i was faculty at texas a m
and then um in the following decade um i
connected with wendell wallach um and uh we did
a fair amount of work thinking about how one would
design algorithms that could possibly improve the
the the the ethical behavior of machines um and
that culminated in the book that jack mentioned um
moral machines teaching robots right from wrong
which actually came out in late 2008 but it has a
copyright date of 2009 and one of the questions
that i've been dealing with over the years
is whether or not what we did all the way
back then is is relevant and i'll we'll try
to show you how it is i mean i think uh uh
accounts uh you know failure to take into
account the lessons of that work is part of
what's behind the failure that i see in the
ask delphi project and indeed in the uber fatality
case so um sort of a guiding idea going all the
way back to that 2000 paper was that you had
two basic strategies for programming machines to
do the right thing so to speak one top down where
your algorithms operate with some sort of explicit
representation of a human design code of conduct
it could be an ethical theory it could be a list
of duties uh various meta-ethical principles
or you could go bottom up and try to develop
algorithms that learn or evolve in response to
the behavior of humans and that's the obvious
track that's been taken with machine learning
rather than the more symbol-driven rule-driven
ai that was uh that predates the current big boom
but even in the 2000 papers i'll show we argued
that there's a need for kind of hybrid systems you
you need both of these and i will try to explain
that a little bit more as we go on but first so
there was very you know various there's always
critical responses to these kinds of books and um
the one that i have taken most seriously since the
release to that book is that there was too much
focus on the machines itself so this is actually
on the left hand side a cartoon from james
gibbs that pre-dates our books some of the
one of the earliest papers on ethical ai towards
the ethical robot was the title of gipps's work
um and he included this diagram was sort of
the goal was to start with a machine and then
end up with a machine that could be thought
to have a halo over it is doing something
better than the the the earlier version and
that um that's very much them focusing on
what kind of algorithms can you build in what
kinds of data do they have to have access to
but the criticism um that i take seriously is that
there's not enough attention in that picture and
indeed in the picture of moral machines to
the entire socio-technical system in which
we embed these machines so i'm just trying to
illustrate that a little bit by throwing a few
people perhaps some of them with halos perhaps all
of them with halos perhaps none of them with halos
in in the context of interactions
with machines and trying to think
about how those kinds of interactions need
to be not just left to some sort of haphazard
let's hope that it works out but but some real
um social engineering if you like and hence the
engineering approach to collective wisdom this
is part as was mentioned of this project that
we've got that's funded by templeton world charity
foundation um on practical wisdom and intelligent
machines so i just put up the splash for our
webpage there i'm not going to dwell on this
but the outline for what i'm going to do is really
to have already given you the motivation for this
and sort of hinted at what the two failures
are that i'm going to use my my base cases
and then walk you through how we're thinking
about wisdom from both philosophical and
psychological perspectives leading us to what
we're calling a componential approach and then
talk about the application of that approach to
engineering wisdom for end users and development
developers although there are other stages in the
in the process but i'm going to focus on those two
um in this talk um one reason i'm going to focus
on those two rather than other stages in the
process of producing these kinds of products is
that it's where i've got the most worked out ideas
and and you know indeed the rest of the grant
which runs until uh the beginning of next year
with brat is going to be to try to work out some
of those other issues for other stages of project
development and produce basically a white paper
for best practices in this area so let's look a
little bit more closely at these two failures so
first the uber fatality um one response that uh
is exemplified by this bloomberg article on the
right hand side here and the headline why not
just retrain pedestrians to make self-driving
vehicles safer in other words maybe the problem
is not in the car but in the person who's walking
in front of this car um and insurance journal has
a commentary uh on bloomberg's uh assumption that
that it's you who's crossing the street wrong
they they say that's essentially the argument
some self-driving car boosters have fallen back on
in the months since the first pedestrian death
attributed to an autonomous vehicle amid growing
concerns that ai capable of real-world driving is
further away than many predicted just a few years
ago and i think this point about it being further
away is actually quite salient um uber is act in
fact divested itself they were based in pittsburgh
they've sold off their self-driving car business
yet around pittsburgh we still see other companies
testing those self-driving vehicles on the streets
and i could anecdotally sort of report to you some
of the the glitches that that i've seen directly
the environment in which these machines operate
is extraordinarily complex so as i say on the
left hand side in the first of these bullet points
the feedback loops make human machine interactions
difficult to predict and so no matter how much
training you've engaged in there's there are
going to be these so-called edge cases or um or
indeed people will learn how to exploit some of
the operations of these machines in order to game
them in a certain way so if you know the vehicles
are programmed to slow down you might just walk
out in front of one expecting it to slow down
um and that creates a kind of feedback
loop between the people's expectations
and the vehicle's performance that then makes
the outcomes really difficult to predict
um and further so so one thought here is that then
training people not to cross the road safely but
to exercise more wisdom in deploying and using
these ai systems may be more effective and
desirable than training the kind of conformity
and bystanders that was suggested by the
by the article that i highlighted
on the right hand side of this slide
so if we take a wisdom approach um it's
important to distinguish that the way
wisdom has been treated in philosophy and
psychology is actually rather different
so the approaches are different and the accounts
that arise from those approaches are different so
within philosophy philosophers have tended towards
conceptual analysis of wisdom so going back to
uh plato the ideas that we gain understanding
of concepts by giving something like a set
of necessary and sufficient conditions so what
is the good you're supposed to come up with some
definition of you know something is good if and
only if and then specify some western conditions
that good things and only good things meet the
concept of wisdom itself is often motivated by
mythical exemplars so the ideal of the fully wise
person and this is more of an aristotelian ideal
is one who is wise in all respects um you you
can't be fully wise unless you have all of the
aristotelian virtues um and that's a nearly
impossible if not impossible uh standard to attain
um but philosophers will talk about this as some
sort of regulative ideal it's something that one
might want to aim towards even if you know that
it's not in fact in practice accomplishable um
psychologists on the other hand of course have
tended towards experimental analysis rather than
conceptual analysis via operationalizing
quantifiable components so the the componential
approach that we end up with is more akin to
the sort of psychological approach nevertheless
we think we're bringing in some features in our
account which i'll give you in a little bit more
detail in a moment um that pick up on some of the
aspects of the kinds of accounts that philosophers
end up with so philosophers as i've already said
tend to emphasize the kind of domain generality
of wisdom the truly wise person is wise in
in in in all domains and also emphasize the
extreme difficulty of attaining wisdom but the
feature that i haven't mentioned so far is the
involvement of what philosophers call ethically
thick concepts so not just good and bad but
you know good in very particular context in
very particular ways so the wise person knows
how to handle very specific situations because
they have these very rich ethical concepts that
apply to those situations so you know
the virtues in in aristotle's case are
geared towards particular situations courage in
one situation is different from courage in another
but they're both morally loaded notions in
those if you've got two different situations
and and so um we tend to de-emphasize in
our account a and b but we do think that
this sort of ethical thickness notion
of wisdom is is appropriate to capture
um psychologists also emphasize though that
um that the outcomes should be attainable in
particular context so they tend to reject uh the
b feature um and even the a feature of uh of the
philosophical accounts and we think that that's
probably a more psychologically realistic way of
thinking about things so our project then is not
conceptual analysis but rather kind of conceptual
engineering we're looking to existing concepts of
wisdom for ideas about how to think about wisdom
in the context that we're interested in
we think it's useful to distinguish wisdom
in a way that i'll also explain in a moment
from nearby concepts such as knowledge or
understanding or skill or expertise we are
focused more on what aristotle thinks of as
practical wisdom rather than theoretical wisdom
and we accept that whatever engineered concept of
wisdom we're going to use in this context should
involve some relatively thick ethical concepts
and as i've mentioned psychologists adopt a
component first approach to wisdom that identifies
and operationalizes quantifiable features that are
attainable by humans they've got to study people
who have these characteristics or are developing
these characteristics after all and they're
localized to and developed in different domains so
if you're bringing in somebody uh and asking how
do they develop wisdom or or some other related
concept like expertise in a particular domain
you're not going to do a study that spans all
domains you're going to focus on that particular
domain but the two components that we want to
focus on in the way we're thinking about wisdom
are breadth of knowledge in the domain so your
knowledge has to apply broadly in that domain you
have to know quite a lot about that domain but the
second feature is one that's often less emphasized
which is what we're calling metacognitive
awareness of the limits of knowledge so the idea
is that the wise person doesn't just know a lot of
stuff about a particular domain they're not just
expert in that domain but they really understand
the limits of their knowledge right they
understand where that knowledge is likely to fail
and this turns out i think to be a very important
way of thinking about how various kinds
of ai projects go wrong i mean it's it's
not uncommon to think of engineers here as
having a kind of hubris based in their their
true expertise that they then are experts in
domains in which they're not for instance ethics
or that there are um they're they they're
overconfident in the domains in which they
are experts so they think that the self-driving
car is going to perform in all kinds of
circumstances and really they don't have very good
calibration about that so what do we do about that
and we think that there are different requirements
of different phases of the product cycle so
you know you could divide the development
of some ai uh application into various
different stages you could do this in various ways
but for today today i'll just be satisfied with
thinking of four stages and these have cycles
so you know you go back and forth on this but
you start with some sort of idea some conception
of something you want to build and and sketch out
the design of that you then get into developing it
by actually writing lines of code that can do what
it is that you want it to do this may cause you
to go back and reconceive what you're doing once
you realize that actually you can't quite figure
out how to program this brilliant idea that you
had so again there's iteration among these parts
but once you've got something that you think is
worthy of release then there's both
marketing and deployment of that and this
brings up its own sorts of ethical um and wisdom
issues you know how should you market some
product wisely so that people understand what
its true limits are and of course then you end
up with operation by end users who are often sat
in the case of the uber car they're sat in a car
i'm told to watch it operating in autonomous mode
they gain a bunch of experience from that it all
seems to be working quite well and so they begin
to sort of pay less attention it's a natural human
response and in fact the woman in that um uber
case was uh known to be texting on her phone
like seconds before this fatality occurred um
you know and it's not unreasonable that she
should have come to expect this card to do
the right thing in in in most circumstances
um and therefore she had let her guard down so she
didn't really understand the limits of the system
she didn't really understand where and when it
could fail and i take that not to be her failing
but a failing of the entire socio-technical
system that put her in that seat um in a
situation where she was almost bound to end up
overestimating his capacities without further
additional kinds of training and that's the kind
of thing that we're trying to think through here
so what are the features then when we're thinking
about wisdom for end users well um one is then
what kinds of strategies for operating these
things are appropriate appropriate and what kinds
of testing of their limits is available so ideally
we'd want to explore excuse me users to be able to
explore what's sometimes called the brittleness
of these systems when do they break and one way
in which you might do that is design some kind
of sandbox some kind of safe space could be a
virtual environment for instance to allow them to
enhance their knowledge of the system's operations
and then gain this kind of metacognitive awareness
of the limits of their own knowledge and the
limits of the system itself and we take it that
this is something that right now is not possible
within the artifact itself the ai itself doesn't
have this kind of metacognitive awareness we don't
really know how to program that in so this remains
something that's present in the interaction
between humans and machine and humans are the ones
that are bringing this capacity to the table so to
speak so for instance perhaps every tesla when
we all have heard of cases where people have
unwisely operated their teslas hands-free
playing games on the console all the rest of it
that has also led to fatalities maybe every tesla
should should come with a requirement just like
for airline pilots to do a certain number of hours
in a simulator where they would learn that when
they're not paying attention bad thing can happen
so so that's an idea of how you might actually
engage end users with the systems in a way
that develops this kind of two component
understanding of how the system does work
and also understanding of where it will fail
another uh element of end users is of course
something that's been talked about a lot in the
literature on ai ethics is the opacity of the
systems meaning that the system being opaque
not transparent we don't really uh understand how
they work particularly in complex machine learning
algorithms um something gets trained up and then
it behaves and and it's very complicated even the
people who who designed and built the system may
lack a certain kind of understanding of why it's
doing the thing that that it's doing um and here
i think one important thing to think about is
what we call the variable value of explainability
to wisdom so depending on where you're thinking
about um wisdom being applied whether it's in the
development stage or whether it's in the marketing
stage or whether it's in the end user stage
um the uh the the kind of explainability that
is helpful for people getting the kind of
metacognitive knowledge of the system that
we're talking about is going to be different so
somebody who programmed or designed the thing
um wants a different kind of explanation from
the end user and so if we're going to think about
opacity versus transparency and explainability of
the systems we can't just have that discussion um
as it were too core for all stages we have to
think very specifically about what that means
in each of the contexts in which people are
interacting with it so when it gets to the
end user um both with the uber case and with the
asdelphi case which i'm going to come back to in
a moment the end user doesn't have a programmer
sitting next to them it doesn't have a designer
sitting next to them they have to figure out
for themselves what what the limits of this
are and that's an interesting case um for uh
asdelphi in particular so i want to go back to
s delphi um i haven't checked the the website for
about three days but it still was operating pretty
much as it was when i put these slides together
um so they had uh this kind of immediate uptake
once it was released and people picked up on this
existence there was a lot of back and forth on
twitter and other social uh social media platforms
where people were um literally testing the limits
of delphi so they were plugging in all sorts
of things such as that example i showed you
near the beginning of the talk about genocide and
getting these responses that were in some cases
um you know not just flat out wrong but actually
offensive and so their response was to go through
at least four very rapid uh iterations so version
1.04 which is the screenshot i'm showing you now
um was in place within a couple of weeks so
by early november they had this version up and
they also added before you could just land on the
as delphi website and start posing scenarios to
it and getting its response they added these
terms and conditions so requiring users to
acknowledge that they understood that this
was just a research tool that you couldn't get
actual ethical advice from it and then i think
the second clause is particularly interesting what
are the limitations of delphi large pre-trained
language models such as gpt-3 are trained they
set it on mostly unfiltered internet data and
therefore are extremely quick to produce toxic
unethical and harmful content especially about
minority groups um so here they sort of basically
say that's what we're doing with delphi that's how
we trained it we extrapolated though in addition
from a survey of u.s crowd workers so amazon
mechanical turk if you're familiar with that
uh kind of platform which helps reduce this
issue but may introduce its own biases thus some
responses from delphi may contain inappropriate
or offensive results please be mindful before
sharing results and so again you have to
check this box to say that you understand that
that this could happen here none of this
was in place when they initially released it
and one of the questions is why wasn't it in place
and why uh why did they release something that'll
produce these kinds of responses um the third
one is just sort of standard privacy and data
collection statement so the the initial
release of the website in october of last year
was accompanied by the release of of
a preprint on the archive.org server
in which they described the the system so this
was not peer-reviewed at that point it was just
placed online and what they say in this paper
is that instead of relying on prescriptive
ethics which is taken top down by prescribing
key elements of ethical judgments we leverage
descriptive or applied norm representations are
listed by a bottom-up approach by asking people's
judgments on various ethical situations
so you can see that they're framing this
very much in the way that i had been framing this
going back to the year 2000 in terms of two broad
strategies but what they do is they say the top
down is useless we are only going to go bottom
up and i'll show you that later but here's an
example of what happened between 1.0 and 1.04
so that first one i've shown you already
the second one if you type in the exact same
prompt in 1.04 it comes back with a warning this
statement may contain unintended offensive content
reader discretion is strongly advised
please be mindful before sharing so
here's my mind i'm sharing it with you should
i commit genocide if it makes everybody happy
it's wrong so they've tweaked their programming
and they've retrained the system to come up
with the different response but it's also very
clear that delphi itself has no awareness that
this change has been made it's just now responding
differently right it's it's a it's a dumb machine
learning system in uh in some sense they've just
retrained it with with more appropriate data
so if we ask what's wrong with bottom up
machines a partial answer is well it needs
top-down mechanisms for reconciling diverse
kinds of knowledge and expertise because
in this crowdsourcing of the responses there's
all kinds of inconsistencies and really
they're just giving us some average in the
initial response the average was wrong they've
biased their training data now so that it
comes out with the right answer but there's
no capacity for any kind of theoretical
analysis of that within the system itself
and in fact if you go in and this is a direct
quote from that uh research paper there is so this
is what they say that they are doing instead of
relying on prescriptive ethics right that's what i
quoted to you before um delphi version 1.04 comes
back and says that's good but if we reframe this
slightly and say well some programmers release
software for public use in which instead of
blah blah blah delphi itself comes back and says
it's not good so this is kind of ironic right so
if you describe what they did they say that's fine
it's it's okay but if you describe them doing it
it says it's not good so the irony is if they just
put in a description of their own activity maybe
they've got a better answer than the one that they
themselves decided was just fine um and but the
main point here is that this kind of um sort of
reflective analysis is completely absent from the
system itself which which further emphasizes
the point that i made at the beginning that
um you know too much focus on the artifact without
thinking about the socio-technical system in which
it's embedded is is not going to get us very
far at the moment so yes mistakes were made and
upon release of the 1.04 version in early november
they published simultaneously an article um
that you see here it's got leeway jang as the
who is the first author of the uh of the research
article as the sole byline here but in fact you
see just underneath it it says buy and it's all
the same authors and they conveniently give us the
too long didn't read summary at the top um in this
article we'd like to share what happened since the
release in october 14 we start with an overview
describe the stress testing of the research
prototype apologize for the mistakes we have made
and share what lessons we have learned and reflect
on why working on imperfect solutions to build
ethically aware and socially responsible machines
is better than in action so even in this they
double down on their bottom-up only approach and
i'll have something more to say about this but i
wanted to you know point out that they apologize
they acknowledge some mistakes but they don't
in fact acknowledge all the mistakes that they
that they made so here's what they said about this
crucially we chose not to ignore the known
problems and biases and large language models
which are implicitly taking unethical or biased
stances and instead aim to develop solutions to
mitigate the biases and harms of these models and
they go on to say we believe that in action or
turning a blind eye in the face of these known
harms is a form of implicit endorsement thus
we should choose to take action to attempt to
reduce these harms knowing very well that any
solution will not be perfect and will require
iterations for improvement and that leaning into
conversations and criticisms will be necessary um
so so they acknowledge that the that their their
product was not perfect they don't acknowledge
that they might have done more beforehand they
acknowledged that they were frankly surprised at
the kinds of things that people on the internet
threw at this system exposed some of the problems
that they then had to retrain the system to avoid
but in fact they doubled down on
their bottom-up approach bottom-up
only approach so here's what they say
about this in the original paper and in the
the subsequent follow-up article they basically
don't change this they say fields like social
science philosophy and psychology have produced a
variety of long-standing ethical theories however
attempting to apply such theoretically inspired
guidelines to make moral judgments of complex
real-life situations is arbitrary and simplistic
so they basically dismiss the entire field
of uh you know ethics philosophical athletics
psychological the kinds of work i was telling you
about earlier um and the social sciences as as not
up to the car the key challenge they say is not to
apply ethical prescriptions but rather understand
moral implications in the context of a wide
variety of everyday situations hence they carry on
instead of relying on prescriptive ethics which is
top down we leverage descriptive or applied norm
representations enlisted by a bottom-up approach
by asking people's judgment in some various
ethical situations um and as i said in the
subsequent thing they really doubled down on that
approach so um i pointed out to one mistake that
they uh acknowledged which was uh that they didn't
anticipate the um the kind of uh interactions that
people would engage with with this thing
and and anybody who knows the history of
people putting ai chat bot type things
on the web will know of this much older
instance i think it's about eight years old now
i don't have the date on this guardian newspaper
article where microsoft released this chatbot
on twitter and other social media platforms
and people immediately started interacting with
tay and um they they um managed to get tay uh
basically propagating really offensive sort of
racist sexist misogynist things by interacting
with it now microsoft may tay learn in real time
from the interactions in which it was engaged
delphi um uh did not in fact they pre-trained
it and then just released it um and then used
the data for future analysis but they were not
learning on the fly nevertheless right um they got
all sorts of interactions with it that they failed
to anticipate so did they ignore tay well no in
one sense they they decided not to do real-time
learning um of the system but yes they ignored
the fact that there's ample uh evidence that once
released to general public use um people would be
doing their best to make this thing respond
in offensive and unethical ways and forcing
them in the end to not only retrain the system but
also put the disclaimer up we're requiring you to
check off on your understanding of it before you
actually interact with it so you sort of wonder
how how on earth does a bunch of programmers
working in this space come up with a conception
of a product that they want to produce and then
do all the software engineering that's required
to produce it and release it and distribute
it and effectively market it although it's
not a commercial product at this point um without
somebody in the room saying wait a second you know
how are people actually going to interact with
this right why why are we just putting it out
there and you know getting whatever blowback falls
and so thinking through the way in which that kind
of awareness of the limits of the system becomes
part of the design process from the very beginning
is where we're aiming in our
collective wisdom machine wisdom
approach did they ignore this well i've
showed you how they just simply dismiss as
simplistic top-down approaches but if you just go
in and google bottom-up and top-down approaches in
google scholar search for that tomorrow machines
which is you know these are words that they're
using in their own paper you come up with a whole
bunch of references of course it's not only me
but you know i have to say it seems a little bit
egotistical to say look at me i'm at the top why
didn't they pay to pay attention to my work but
i'm not the only one out there discussing this
stuff um and they absolutely ignored this so if
you look at the citations that they have in the in
their paper right it's it's really showing hardly
any awareness to the current literature on this
um the um the stuart armstrong paper actually
is not an ethics paper it's about methods in
metaphysics the hair paper is from 1981. jim
moore is writing about it in 2006 partly in
interaction with the work that i'm doing but
he's not talking about top down bottom up
thomas reed from 1788 and judith jarvis thompson
because of her contribution to the development of
trolley problems which are you know preeminent in
a lot of the discussion of self-driving vehicles
so so they're really they really just didn't do i
mean it's it's it's it's really kind of a stunning
lack of scholarship i will say that quite bluntly
um did they ignore this well you know right again
in my own work we've been saying from the
beginning you can't get away with just bottom
up or top down you've got to do a hybrid whereas
they just say top down won't work so we're going
bottom up that's just in my view irresponsible
right and just a couple more piece of evidence
that even going back in the to the 2000 article
um highlighted at the bottom there we we said
that it's possible that the hybrid approach
might be able to combine the best of each but
the problem requires further analysis and that's
what we were trying to do in the subsequent work
and then again you know there are best books
on ethics for ai there's moral machines again
but there are others where this is discussed and
i'm not going to do well on this this is just so
one of the things that that gets highlighted is
just how complex these issues are and what kind
of careful thought as as uh paula bobington writes
right exposing the level of detail we need to be
asking about machines and morality to be able to
answer these questions is really critical and and
there's just a lack of attention to the details
here and again we have a whole chapter and book on
merging talk down and bottom up anyway so enough
about me and uh and my writing about uh their sort
of failure to pay attention to the stuff that's
in the literature um were the mistakes inevitable
well that's really what we're trying to address
in in our machine wisdom project um and i've
already sketched for you the engineered concept
of wisdom that we're dealing with one where it
has two dimensions one you do have to know quite
a bit about the the situation or the system that
you're dealing with and that is acquired bottom up
with practice guided by theory but then you also
have to have this metacognitive awareness of the
limits of that knowledge and that's required by
limits testing and i think that these two
dimensions are absent in current ai development
current ai itself sorry if you think about
the artifact i think we don't know how to
build these kinds of things into the ai itself
and it's insufficiently present in the teams
that are developing um and so what we're really
facing here is a battle against low metacognition
in the machine where it's incapable uh perhaps
in the people survey but in particular in the
computer scientists who are building these things
and it's it's a case of something that has been
discussed in this area where having a whole
bunch of expertise actually leads to a kind of
overconfidence um and sort of even a reduced
uh level of metacognition about the limits
of that knowledge and we see that i think
very much in a lot of the engineering where
by where they've got real expertise in developing
these systems they don't want to knock that at all
um but then that they seem to think that that
qualifies them to be experts about ethics as
well and they really need to understand
that they need input from other sources
so our confidential approach this is basically
the summary of my final slide although i'll tell
you about upcoming workshop in a moment um but um
a confidential approach focuses on understanding
the limits of systems testing them in order to
get those uh that gate to get that understanding
and what's needed are multiple perspectives
and abilities to maximize the impact of testing
in perhaps safe sandbox environments but even
before you get to that stage you can't sandbox
something you haven't built yet we need better
sociotechnical structures to enhance metacognitive
awareness of the limits and potential problems at
all stages and what we're developing we hope is a
kind of pragmatic framework for systematic
interdisciplinary approach that can involve
engineers philosophers cognitive and
behavioral scientists academics corporate
government and public structures to make sure
that the that somebody is in the room at the
appropriate time to say hey hang on a moment
you shouldn't be putting this out there yet
right we need to do more thorough testing we need
to make sure the system's more robust so if you go
to our website for the machine wisdom project
which you see here you'll find that we have a
workshop coming up in pittsburgh for those of you
who don't know pittsburgh this is the cathedral of
learning um we'll be uh on the 11th floor of this
building um may 12th to 14th with the deadline
for submissions has already passed but it'll be an
open conference anybody's welcome to attend where
we have a number of psychologists and philosophers
um and computer scientists on the program
this is a second workshop we had to do the last
one virtually an invitation only last year this is
more open we've got contributed as well as invited
papers and and it's to talk through and work
through these issues and try to come up with
some best practices and that will assist brett
and i in writing up the white paper so with that
that's my final slide um thanks very much for your
attention i'm looking forward to questions colin
thank you so much you know as i was listening
to you talk i was kind of thinking about some
of the stories you described especially where
you mentioned that sort of ai engineering hubris
and the sort of just disconnection between
you know what can be done what should be done
and how it's deployed and i can understand that
after people hear you present that people
are probably mad right at the ask delphi
you know or you know others who are developing
these technologies and completely dismissing
you know centuries of prior literature um you
know especially you know current thinking about
how to deploy these things in ai you know
what what sort of reaction do you get from
these you know individuals who are developing
this stuff when you present this to them
do they get defensive do they say oh yes we know
that we're just not going to bother with it i
don't know what some sort of reaction yeah so
well i haven't had a chance yet to present this
directly to them so um so far this is um the
first time i've given this particular talk
um although some of the material is drawn from
two talks that were separate so so i had a talk
that was about developing the framework and i had
a talk that was just about delphi but i've given
that delphi talk only in a couple of very small
venues and so i don't know if they're aware of
it yet but we are writing up a paper that we will
be submitting to um some fairly prominent place um
and i also have under consideration sort of an
op-ed piece that i hope will come out and make
a big splash uh elsewhere i have no idea if it'll
get picked up those things are always a little bit
uh variable in terms of that that's right um
so so yeah um i so i don't have any direct um
thing to say about this particular project in
response to these particular criticisms of this
particular project what i will say though is
there are genuine and sincere people working in
these spaces who do want to do the right thing
um and i think they also get embarrassed when
they have colleagues who who ignore a whole bunch
of what could have been helpful information and
and don't do the right thing um and and uh but but
those who want to stick to their guns and remain
dismissive of philosophy i think often frame it
in terms of this what they see from a distance
is a kind of stagnation in the field why am i
still talking about plato and aristotle you know
that's 2 000 years ago what relevance is that to
me you know the world has changed kind of response
and and that's a communication problem and i
think any i've done a lot of interdisciplinary
work over my career and it it really takes
at least a year of like you know regular
dialogue for people to begin to understand other
where people are coming from on these issues so
so it's a long-term project to do that you
can't just waltz in and go you guys are all
wrong although you know some of my perhaps
some of my sort of uh shock at just how badly
i think stealthy was done um perhaps go through
here so i'm being a little harsher than i'm at
uh you know that's all right i would try
to understand why they think that this was
appropriate before i i did this but um yeah so
it's a matter of establishing a dialogue and i and
i think this is what's behind our machine wisdom
project just trying to come up with processes
right everybody understands process so so
if you can come up with processes by which
you could potentially um um uh get the right
people in the room and who are the right people
that's a big question um so you know if we could
potentially get the right people in the room and
having these conversations before it's too late
i think then everybody would benefit from that
the other thing i'll say about this sorry going on
perhaps a bit too long but but the uh you know i
think the other way in which people in um in these
technical fields dismiss philosophers and others
um who are doing this adjacent work is by saying
oh well they just don't understand the technology
and my thing in my case i think that's completely
false i think i can give you a you know a pretty
solid introduction to gpt3 and how it works and
i do neural network programming myself and i've
got a number of programming projects myself so so
i think i have that kind of technical knowledge
that will convince them fairly quickly that i
do know what i'm talking about when it comes to
the technical aspects of this um but it's a real
danger i think in a lot of the discourse between
ephesus and technologists is that ethicists
say things that make the technologists
kind of really wonder how well they understand
the technologies that they're criticizing
but on the other side one of our uh listeners
here it kind of asks an important question is the
assumption by the delphi um programmers that all
the you know all the web pages all the documents
that they're sucking into their machine
are all unbiased and that these are all
you know there's no realization that these might
be created by humans with particular biases or
points of view that gets embedded in
the system do they just not seem to
gather that yeah good so that gives me a chance
to sort of explain what they did differently from
the gpt um family of approaches so it doesn't
really matter whether you've heard of gpt but
one approach a bottom approach is take a
bunch of tax and then try to figure out
what the response be should be to any prompt
from what's learned from that text and then those
responses are definitely going to require the
biases that exist in the text that are selected
and the um the delphi team did something a
little bit different from the developers of gpt-3
um which is they they built a curated data set
in other words they didn't just scrape everything
they could off the internet in the way that the
gpt developers did they only took selected things
so they if you go into their paper they'll list
the categories of things that they use in order
to provide the starting point for their project
but the second thing that they did differently
is they then delphi is not driven by some machine
learning just over those attacks they then take
scenarios little vignettes if you like from
that curated set of documents which will
contain you know both bad things and good things
descriptions of uh you know atrocities or crimes
versus descriptions of good acts and uh you know
one might even say saintly acts right so they so
they try to build a corpus that's focused
on that kind of thing then they take these
scenarios and present them to the the emter
the amazon mechanical turf workers and say
given the scenario what's your rating of it
right so so they get they crowd source there for
a whole bunch of responses and they assume that
their sample of responders may contain a range
of a range of views about what ethics is but they
also assume that the societal norm is something
like the dominant tendency within those responses
that they get now you might at this point go well
you know there are going to be biases in in
the people who are given the responses and
and i think that they would acknowledge that
but the the training of delphi itself is based
on not the text but on the human responses
to the text wow right so yes that does the
human responses have their own source of bias you
might wonder whether or not you're also sampling
the the right the you know whether you've got
the right population sample but they but they
explicitly take a kind of relativistic stance
towards um towards ethics so they would say you
know even though we're only sampling you know
some portion of the american or north american
population it's their norms that we want
to represent in this product right because
at one of the quotes i read more or less said
this explicitly right the goal is identifying
the norms within a particular group right so if
the norms are different somewhere else that's fine
they would say we can train delphi to
give the appropriate response over there
they adopt this uh this sort of relativistic
meta ethics right so they dismiss meta ethics
yet they pick a position in in meta ethics
which is actually one of the least defensible
positions in meta ethics and in fact i've got a
whole bunch of slides that i couldn't fit in today
in which i prompt zelfie with various statements
about kantianism and utilitarianism and
virtue theory and relativistic ethics and its own
responses to those prompts are as incoherent as
you might imagine they would be there's there's
simply no consistency in the way delphi itself
responds to um to meta-ethical scenarios i'm i'm
curious i mean have you explored because where
of course the theme of our particular medical data
science seminar series is biomedicine and medicine
and health i'm curious if you have any examples
of such systems which have failed spectacularly
in the uh biosciences or in you know in
health and medicine well probably the one the
is best known or at least the one i'm most
familiar with is ibm watson's deployment right
have you talked about that in your series we
haven't but uh if you want to give us a call
okay sure so so ibm watson um um made a big
splash a dozen years ago or 10 years ago by
defeating ken jennings and another leading
jeopardy contestant you know one of the top ever
prize winners in uh staged uh jeopardy competition
um and so uh so that made a huge splash it's sort
of like you know beating the chess grandmaster
or beating like a master right it was winning
at jeopardy against the best human players at the
time in jeopardy and uh the technology underlying
um um watson is not um a machine learning neural
network approach as uh delphi and and gpt-3 are
but it's rather a more standard sort of data text
mining from uh reliable sources on the internet
you know reliable meaning wikipedia level
reliability which you know i use wikipedia
for a lot of things it's pretty good in
some areas it's not so great in the other
in other areas and but not just that they they
they used a whole bunch of things including
in fact the stanford encyclopedia philosophy
right this was one of their sources for that
um and and it's a question answering system so
just in jeopardy format i mean the you know the
gimmick in jeopardy is you get an answer and
you're supposed to respond with a question
you get a statement and you have to respond
with a question but that's just a gimmick
they're really at the core of it it's it's you
know here's a question and you have to come up
with the right answer for it and so they then
use this sort of big success i mean the whole
reason that ibm wants to do something like this
and make a big media splash is then turn around
to to the medical community and say we can do
the same thing for you know disease diagnosis
or uh you know disease treatment plans
and so on so if you haven't looked it up
they they built such a system they deployed
it um and um and and it turned out to be
nowhere near as uh good as uh you know ibm had
made it out to be and uh i don't have the exact
website or reference to hand right now but
i've got a slide from another talk in which
you know a doctor a big hospital in the new york
area saying this thing is basically crap right
so so there's a you know a very prominent
case of failure in the biomedical area
that said you know machine learning i think
is doing quite a lot for helping in radiology
you know skin cancer detection that kind
of thing although again there are limits
so the darker your skin the harder it is for
the machine to make a correct judgment about
a melanoma and there are other kinds of problems
and again you know really to have proper
wise collectively wise use in this socio-technical
system of this product you can't just show up and
say and give a bunch of radiologists sort of
training on how to feed images into the machine
and get the machine's response out i think you've
got to give them something that enables them much
more to understand underwater conditions that
will go wrong not just when it will go right
and of course from a marketing standpoint
that's the last thing that they want to get yeah
they don't want that right they don't want that
it was funny because you were talking about um
you started with talking about autonomous vehicles
and i yeah i'm i'm old but i'm still uh able to
remember when i was learning how to drive and one
of the things that you know the driving instructor
would try to drill into you is you know be a
defensive driver trying to anticipate what's the
most stupid thing the driver next to you is going
to do and anticipate that they're going to do it
and you still kind of do this to this day right
is you kind of like go that guy's going to change
lanes without his signal and cut me off and you
just could see it coming uh a lot of the machines
that are being built do not have that kind of
defensive driving situational awareness built
into them they are following an algorithm and you
know if the algorithm says that's the answer then
that's it but they they rarely take into account
context situation you know skin color you know
those types of things just don't get factored
in um so it's it's a such an interesting area
with so many different nuance directions to go so
i'll mention one other failure and this was at the
summer olympics so the winter ones just
wrapped up but the summer olympics in beijing
they were using autonomous vehicles to
shuttle athletes from dormitories to venues
and they used this vehicle system without
incident during the olympics and then came
the paralympics and within a day or two they
had an incident where one of these things
actually hit a competitor in a crosswalk
who was blind right why did nobody think
that at the paralympics you're a blind you know
this system was not trained with the idea that
people might not actually see and take evasive
action and this illustrates another point
when it comes to interactions with these actually
quite dumb systems for all the hype that they're
intelligent and so on um it's always the humans
that have to adapt because these systems have very
little or no adaptive capacity themselves people
are the ones who have to make the adaptation and
often the adaptation we make is not good and you
know it also has ethical ramifications um and so
probably in the you know in the regular summer
olympics people would see these things lumbering
towards them and walk in a way that would
make sure that they didn't get run over by
it but a blind person doesn't see it right
they're not going to take this they don't
have the same adaptive capacity yet i mean the
vehicle sort of trained around humans that do
have that adaptive capacity and and the result
is a problem the person was not scarcely hurt
but they were you know it was a it was something
that could have been a lot worse and could have
prevented them from competing um at all right well
colin thank you so much you've given us a lot to
think about this was a fascinating presentation
uh great chat um about a very interesting area
i hope that anybody who's watching uh takes
advantage of uh the machine wisdom project.org
conference which is coming up it sounds super
exciting if you're in the pittsburgh area or
feel like traveling to pittsburgh uh go
uh go visit colin and his colleagues there
that sounds like it's going to be a really
thought-provoking opportunity so thank you again
colin really appreciate it thank you everyone
for joining us and we'll see you next week